[musique]
riz au sarrasin
huile végétale sucre thé c'est quelque chose
doux, ajoute des bonbons au thé
Ici
[musique]
Pas
très sidorov maintenant plus rien du tout
tu ne peux pas acheter si je pouvais imaginer avant
laisse sortir nourrir quelque chose maintenant même
nos céréales sont très chères, j'espère
personne ne me jugera, j'ai dit la vraie chose
la vérité donc maintenant je n'en stocke déjà plus
j'y vais dans les jours
qu'est-ce qu'il y a assez de miel ici
[musique]
mais beaucoup de gens ont commencé à venir
qui, semble-t-il, pourrait gérer
sans notre aide si ce n'est à cause de la pandémie
[musique]
les autorités, pour des raisons évidentes, attribuent
l'inflation se concentre sur la hausse des prix des
Nourriture
ce sujet, ce problème est très
sensible pour les Russes, et ce
la sensibilité est toujours connue de
notre passé des années 90
[musique]
[applaudissements]